Trascrizione: Roberto Minelli
Revisore: Michele Gianella
"Giocare è una cosa seria",
affermava Bruno Munari,
uno dei più grandi
liberi pensatori del secolo scorso,
e il mio più grande riferimento.
Ho preso questa frase alla lettera,
e l'ho condita con gli studi passati
in grafica e in architettura.
Ho presto capito che, però,
la progettazione urbana e l'architettura
proprio non facevano per me.
Eppure non sarà un caso,
se il primo giocattolo
che ho pensato, disegnato, realizzato
è stato proprio una città: Archiville.
Archiville è una città in cartone
in cui ogni parte di questo gioco
è un pezzo della città.
C'è un edificio, una casa,
una strada, una fontana,
ognuno dei quali presenta un incastro,
un invito ad un incastro
per costruire la città
in maniera sempre libera.
L'unica regola di questo gioco
è che non ci sono regole,
se non quella di farsi guidare
dalla libera immaginazione,
dalla libera creazione.
Si possono mettere
gli alberi sopra le case;
le case sopra i fiumi;
i fiumi sopra le colline.
Si possono costruire delle archiville
lunghe, orizzontali, verticali;
oppure delle archiville
compatte, ammonticchiate.
Mi è capitato di fare
molti workshop, con questo gioco:
ed è stato incredibile vedere
come tanti bambini costruivano
tante archiville diverse.
Ricordo, durante uno di questi laboratori,
come una bambina in particolare
usasse soltanto parti verdi:
alberi, colline, montagne, prati.
Ed ha colpito incredibilmente
la mamma, fervida cittadina,
che si è chiesta se non fosse il caso
di portarla un po' più in natura.
A partire da Archiville,
ho delineato in modo sempre più chiaro
i principi che guidano
la progettazione dei miei giocattoli.
Sapete,
giocare è la prima forma di apprendimento
attraverso la quale i bambini,
fin dai primissimi mesi di età,
imparano ad esplorare
il mondo che li circonda.
Imparano i principi di accostamento,
i colori, le forme, il peso.
E questo vale sia per i giocattoli
di nuova invenzione
e anche per quelli
tradizionali, esistenti,
in cui le regole possono essere cambiate
per creare delle interazioni
completamente nuove.
Prendiamo ad esempio il domino,
un gioco che tutti conosciamo:
ci abbiamo giocato.
Ogni tesserina ha due estremità,
in cui ci sono due numeri;
e vanno accostati ai corrispondenti
di un'altra tesserina.
Cosa succede se, invece dei numeri,
mettiamo dei frammenti di un disegno?
Immaginate: prendiamo l'illustrazione,
dividiamola in parti creando
delle sezioni piccole, medie e grandi,
e queste sezioni sono la regola
di accostamento ad altre tessere analoghe.
Seguendo la regola del domino,
andiamo a creare dei disegni,
delle composizioni sempre nuove,
in questo caso degli animali,
delle creature fantastiche,
in un'avventura visiva superstimolante,
innovativa e nuova, per i bambini.
Partendo da qui, abbiamo creato un gioco
sopra un altro gioco esistente.
I bambini imparano
a categorizzare il mondo
attraverso icone, simboli universali
che rappresentano gli edifici,
gli oggetti, la natura, i paesaggi.
Sono capaci di vedere,
in un palazzo rosso con le scale,
la caserma dei pompieri.
In una linea verde disegnata
in un foglio, il prato.
Questo è un principio
incredibilmente importante
che distingue i giocattoli
che io chiamo innovativi e stimolanti
rispetto a quelli che io definisco
dei pupazzi statici.
Definizione che non implica
alcun tipo di giudizio:
sono soltanto dei prodotti fatti e finiti
che rappresentano
il supereroe del momento,
o il personaggio di un cartone animato,
o di una Barbie.
Sono dei prodotti
perfettamente realizzati,
che però non creano alcun tipo
di interazione elaborata.
Sono perfetti per quello che si chiama
gioco simbolico, di finzione:
per esempio quando si portano
in giro due bambole,
o quando Superman
combatte contro il mostro.
Ecco: io non progetto
quel tipo di giocattoli.
Cerco di togliere il più possibile
ai miei prodotti,
diciamo [che sono] quasi
prodotti incompleti.
C'è bisogno della magia del gioco,
del giocare del bambino,
che, attraverso queste
sue azioni, questo gioco,
riesce a completare l'oggetto,
completare il prodotto:
lo rende reale, lo rende vivo.
Per esempio "Cavalcade",
questa collezione di animali a dondolo
che vedete alle mie spalle,
è realizzato a partire
da un unico asse di legno
tagliato in varie parti, poi colorato;
e va a definire una serie di animali.
Non sono dei reali animali:
più che raffigurazioni
di animali reali, sono delle icone.
Quindi la giraffa la si capisce
perché c'è il collo lungo e giallo,
la zebra perché ha
delle striature bianche e nere:
anche se è uguale,
per dimensione e per forma,
al cavallo.
Ci avete mai pensato che
"I bambini vivono in un mondo di adulti"?
Ce l'ha raccontato Enzo Mari:
ed è per questo che hanno bisogno
di un mondo alla loro dimensione
e alla loro misura,
con cui potersi confrontare,
con cui potersi conoscere
e con cui imparare.
Ed ecco, quindi, che i giocattoli
diventano gli strumenti perfetti per loro,
per poter imparare.
Sono degli oggetti esattamente fatti
con un linguaggio loro consono,
alla loro misura, alla loro proporzione.
Durante il cantiere
di una scuola per l'infanzia,
l'architetto ha deciso
di invitare i propri clienti
ad una visita, in questo caso i bambini.
Eccitati, e felici,
di questa incredibile avventura
che stavano per fare,
hanno fatto notare all'architetto
come dall'interno delle loro aule
non riuscissero a vedere l'esterno:
le finestre erano troppo alte.
Ci avete mai pensato?
Ho voluto giocare
con questo scarto di scala
nell'ultimo grande progetto,
in tutti i sensi, che ho realizzato:
"Animal Factory".
È una collezione di animali
realizzata in tubolari d'acciaio,
in scala reale,
che rappresentano animali diversi.
Sono degli oggetti
da mettere nelle scuole,
nei parchi pubblici, nelle città,
nelle aree fitness.
Sono oggetti che invitano
alle interazioni più diverse.
Ci si può appendere, ci si può dondolare,
ci si può sedere,
ci si può legare la bicicletta,
ci si può fare un esercizio
fisico completo.
Possono diventare
anche dei punti d'incontro.
Pensate quanto bello sarebbe,
darsi appuntamento "alla giraffa",
o "al coccodrillo".
Per la prima volta,
mi sto confrontando col fatto
di non essere soltanto un progettista,
ma anche un genitore
di un piccolo Galileo.
che ha poco più di un anno.
Ed osservo in modo critico
come lui sia attirato in egual modo
dai giocattoli che noi consideriamo
creativi e stimolanti,
che da quelli più commerciali,
più privi di senso.
Mi chiedo quale sia l'importanza
di presentare più gli uni
rispetto agli altri;
e credo fermamente
che sia molto importante dare
quelli che stimolano la fantasia
e l'immaginazione del bambino.
E non è di certo il materiale,
a determinarla.
Allora mi chiedo perché noi,
tanti genitori che ci riteniamo moderni
e attenti a questi principi,
ci ostiniamo a prendere
dei prodotti in legno, belli,
che per di più costano molto di più
rispetto a quelli in plastica.
Penso che la risposta sia
"Perché è davvero importante,
educare i bambini alla bellezza".
Alla bellezza intesa
come accostamento di forme di colore.
come suono dei materiali,
come tatticità,
come composizione,
come design.
Sulla stessa linea di principio,
mi chiedo quale sia,
con l'avanzare dell'età del bambino,
il limite tra analogico e digitale,
tra i giochi che scegliamo noi adulti
e quelli che invece vorrà lui, bambino,
perché visti alla tv,
ispirati al cartone animato
o visti dal compagno di classe.
Sono certo che le imposizioni assolute
non siano mai positive.
Come in ogni cosa,
serve buon senso ed equilibrio.
Ciò che è importante,
per noi genitori e progettisti,
è di non vivere un pianeta diverso,
lontano dalla realtà, ma essere qui oggi.
Essere in grado di rispondere
alle loro domande.
Ecco che uno tra i tanti
temi sensibili attuali
è sicuramente quello
della forma del corpo,
della diversità, dell'identità,
dell'inclusione.
Credo che sia giusto, e importantissimo,
educare i bambini a questi temi,
anche attraverso il gioco,
insegnargli l'accoglienza,
il rispetto e l'accettazione.
E concludo il mio discorso
con l'ultimo gioco.
È un memory, si chiama "Siamo tutti pari".
Non è un memory tradizionale,
dove vanno accoppiate
le tessere identiche.
È un memory diverso, perché è
un memory delle parti del corpo:
e proprio enfatizza la diversità.
Mi ripeto, non bisogna cercare
due tessere uguali:
bisogna cercare due tessere simili.
e quindi ci sono due mani,
una con la pelle scura
e una con la pelle chiara.
Ci sono due orecchi:
uno ha un orecchino e uno è senza.
Ci sono due gambe: una ha la protesi,
e una ha la cicatrice.
E poi ci sono anche quattro tessere
che rappresentano le parti intime.
Perché quattro?
Perché credo che ora, nel 2022,
sia giusto e importante educare
i bambini e le bambine
che le libertà che non ledono gli altri
debbano essere considerate un diritto,
e che non ci sia
un giusto e uno sbagliato.
Non pensate?
(Applausi)